okay so in this first lecture I want to
ask a question the question
is why did Humanity transition from
Hunter gather Society to agriculture
okay and in the traditional Paradigm
okay
Paradigm Paradigm is um a very
sophisticated English word and all it
means is
story or model or understanding okay so
in in the traditional story Paradigm we
transitioned
because we're first hunter
gatherers and we lived in groups of
about 20 to 50 people and we roam the
land looking for food it was uncertain
it was
unstable and then suddenly there was a
revolution we discover farming and
farming provided a stable source of food
that we could control okay the word we
use is
domestication okay domestication just
means that we bring it under our
control and because of
farming we can now create more food than
we need the word we use for this is
Surplus and because there's a
surplus people now could do things
besides farming so for example we could
have um leaders which creates the idea
of politics right we could also have
priests which introduces the idea of
religion and then we can have creative
people which then gives us
arts and slowly over time these Villages
grew into cities
and because there was a lot of people
and a lot of surplus we could now have
literature reading and writing so we can
now store knowledge and then pass it
from generation to generation and across
cultures okay we can now have science
and
technology and slowly over the course of
this process we create modernity
okay which is the world that we live in
today so the pivotal
step towards modernity was this
transition into
Agriculture and this is traditionally
what we believed about the
world unfortunately there's no evidence
for this okay and in fact the more
evidence we collect the more we realize
this is not
true in fact
what we now know is it was actually
pretty
stupid to transition from hunter
gatherer into
farming okay for a variety of reasons
the first reason is that when you're a
hunter gatherer it's actually a pretty
easy life because there's food
everywhere okay when you're a farmer
it's a hard life because you have to
grow that food so maybe maybe as a
hunter gatherer you're working maybe an
hour a day
but as a farmer you were working six
seven hours a day it was very hard to
grow that food so in the book um
sapiens the
Israeli um historian named yuel Harari
he's very famous sapen is also a very
famous book there's a very famous
sentence okay the sentence is like this
we did not
domesticate
wheat wheat
domesticated us okay so we F that we
made wheat okay the food wheat into our
slave but in
reality wheat made us its
slave and the reasoning for this is this
out in nature if you're wheat and you
want to survive you have to make
yourself attractive to other people and
to animals okay so you have to be tasty
and you have to be easy to fine you have
to do a lot of work but when you're on a
farm in your wheat you can just lay back
do nothing and make humans do all the
work okay so it was a bad deal for
humans and a very good deal for wheat
okay so that's the first problem you
actually do more work on the farm than
you do as a hunter gatherer which means
that now you have to have more children
right you need to have Labor to do all
that work which creates a problem all
overpopulation which means that you are
using too much land and then eventually
the land becomes dead okay
or uh not arabo anymore so that's the
first problem second problem is that
we're able to dig up the skeletons of
hunter gatherers and farmers and what we
and what we see is that um Hunter
gathers are a lot taller than Farmers
why
protein right food as a hund gatherer
you have access to
meat you have access to fruits and nuts
and vegetables okay your diet is varied
um and very nutritious but as a farmer
you're eating only what you grow which
is mainly wheat and some vegetables okay
so you're not getting that much
nutrition then the third problem is that
is as a farmer you are much more likely
to die early than if you're a hunter
gatherer
why have you guys been to a farm what's
the problem problem on a
farm exactly thank you pigs right
animals they're everywhere plus where do
you put the garbage where do you go to
the restroom right so because people are
together in a very unclean place it's
much more likely to contract disease and
then
die okay so for these three
reasons the
transition from Hunter gather to farming
makes no sense and even today we are not
able to explain to you why this
transition
happened okay we don't know why why we
did
this so the only thing we can do is
construct theories as to why this might
have happened so even though we can't go
in the
past and look at why we did this we can
do some research and collect evidence
and then create theories as to why this
might have happened okay so there are
four different disciplines from which we
can collect evidence the first
discipline is called
archaeology Archaeology is just the
study of the past so basically you go
and you dig stuff up and you see what
you can find okay maybe you can dig up
someone's house or you can take up
someone's skeleton or someone's um
clothing okay and from that you're able
to figure out what happened in the past
and so three pieces of evidence from AR
archaeology we will look at today are go
tape
Jericho and Kaya Hoak okay
and these are places that we've actually
dug up and we know what life is like in
these three
places that's so that's archaeology
second discipline we can look at is
anthropology and
anthropology um is the study of other
cultures so in other words There Are
Places still on this planet where people
live a hunter gatherer
lifestyle maybe in the Amazon maybe in
our Australia maybe in Africa okay and
so we're able to go and study these
people to understand why how originally
we thought and why we might have
transitioned into farming okay so
anthropology the Third Field that we can
look at is
psychology or
Neuroscience basically how the brain
works how do we feel what motivates us
why do we behave the way we behave
okay so that's a third field we can look
at the last field we can look at is
primatology the study of primates okay
or
monkeys because guess what guys we're
monkeys we're primates 99% of our DNA
are monkey DNA so we can look at certain
groups of monkeys to understand how they
behave and there are three types of um
primates that we look at very closely
okay the first is
gorillas we also look at
champanes and we look at uh Bol BS okay
uh chenes and bonobos are very close to
us genetically they're the closest uh to
us of all the primates so um by looking
at these four different fields we're
able to collect evidence to construct
theories as to why we transition from
hunter gatherer into farming okay so now
I will share some of these theories with
you and again what's really important to
understand is we don't know what
happened we can only guess about what
happened so the first theory is the idea
of
cotion okay and what this basically
means is that there's an elite group of
people who didn't want to work so they
made everyone else
work okay so that's cion and the
evidence for this is is that well guess
what gorillas do this right if you study
gorillas you will see that they always
have an alpha male the male who's bigger
than everyone else and who makes
everyone do all the work he just sits
and naps every day but he gets all the
girls and he gets all the food okay so
gorillas that's the first Theory the
second theory
is war
okay and the idea here is that if you
are on a farm it's easier to protect
yourself in a time of War than you're
out in the forest right you can build
walls around your
farm you can uh defend yourself a lot
easier you can see the enemy coming okay
so um War the evidence for this is that
chimpanzees okay again who are like us
they go to war a lot they're very
violent they're always funing each other
so the argument here is that uh we human
beings are just a
violent people who are always at War and
we must be afraid of each other and
therefore when when we have the chance
we'll settle down build fortifications
build walls and fight each other okay
that's a second theory and again the
evidence for this um are champanes the
third theory is um
respect for
elders meaning that as a h 100
gatherer it's very hard on old people
right so at a certain point you're going
to have to leave the old people to just
stay there and die and maybe we as human
beings we are biologically programmed to
take care of Elders for whatever reason
okay and again uh the evidence for this
is
anthropology where every culture
respects its Elders right so so that's a
third Theory the last theory is
religion okay meaning that we settle
down in order to
celebrate a religion to practice a
religion and uh just to be clear um
there's evidence and Arguments for all
four theories and there are Scholars who
argued for different theories okay but
the consensus what most people agree on
today okay most Scholars not every
scholar but most Scholars
is religion okay so let me explain why
we think the answer has to be religion
slowly all right okay so porion
while it is true that with gorillas
there's an alpha
male who controls everything the problem
is that if you look at
gorillas the alpha male is huge okay and
males are a lot bigger than
females so it's possible for one gorilla
to
exert force and pressure on the others
okay with human beings that's harder
right because let's just say a 9 foot
giant human being comes into this room
and it's like I'm now your boss you have
to you have to grow food for me you have
to give me all your woman okay what can
we do as a
class beat the crap out of him okay you
understand because we have big brains
and these big brains allow us to
cooperate together okay so this guy is
around
and at first we're afraid of him so we
let him do whatever he wants but then he
goes to bed and then the and then we as
a class discuss hey what can we do well
we can make weapons right or we can trap
him or we can trick him we can give him
poison food okay so
coercion among humans is very very hard
to do the worst case scenario scenario
we can't beat them up what we'll do is
just run away okay doesn't does that
make sense so we don't think cotion is
an
explanation because there's so many ways
for us to fight back and to rebel
against uh bigger people okay so uh
cotion doesn't really work
War okay so we don't think war is a good
explanation either so it is true that
champanes are naturally violent okay
they're always being the crap out of
each other but guess what
Bob who are actually closer to us
genetically than champanes they're
actually very peaceful they don't fight
each other okay so there's no evidence
that we human beings are naturally
violent
also if it is war
then we should be able to find
weapons um and we don't really find
weapons okay in archaeology we don't
really find weapons of early
humans now there is a lot of violence in
in early human history okay there
there's human sacrifice there's group
bual where a group of people are killed
but that's basically um violence within
a group we don't find
evidence of large violence among
different groups okay we don't find that
so War we don't really think is a
possibility now it's possible that in
the future we'll find evidence but I'm
just saying that right now in
archaeology and anthropology we do not
have any EV any evidence
okay the last then we look at respect
for
elders and even though this is a
Theory um there's an argument that back
then they didn't really care about dying
that much the reason why is that for
most of human history we human beings
have seen life history as a circle right
so for
example um right now it's summer it's
going to turn into fall then winter then
spring then summer again okay so the
world history moves in a cycle well
human life also moves in a cycle you're
born you die then you're reborn then you
die again then you're reborn again okay
so back then they really didn't care if
you die in fact if you're an old person
you're probably like you know what I
rather be dead and then so if I'm if I
die I'll either be reborn or I'll go
into the spirit World okay so they
didn't really fear death or they really
didn't see death like the way we saw
death
yeah okay that's a great question okay
so the evidence for this is what we
understand about their religion which we
we will discuss later on and in next
class okay all
right um the last so that leaves
religion as the most likely uh
possibility and this again this is what
most dos
believed happen and so we're going to
look at three different archaeological
sites the first is
goe the second is Jericho and the third
is K Hoak okay all right so um I'm going
to draw up
a I'm we we'll first see a picture of
goe
and guys um these places were only
discovered in the
past few decades okay so these are new
places we're only starting to understand
these places and um so this place is in
Turkey in central turkey and this dates
back about 9500 BC so this is this is
about over 11,000 years
old um and we don't even think this is
the oldest place okay so if you did your
research you will know that this is
basically a place of religious worship
you can see that um they constructed
this place so that there are these
t-shaped pillars okay and these and
these things are huge right this is a
human being and this is a t-shaped
pillar okay we think again this is all
Theory okay this is all what we know we
don't know that much because this is all
recent okay but we think
that these t-shapes represent
uh human beings okay and Within These
t-shapes are animals and you can see
that they've
aligned or they built this this t-shape
in a way that they can practice a ritual
or a worship okay so the people who are
leading this were probably who we call
shamans okay or religious leaders that
help us Bridge our world with the animal
world and the spirit world okay so these
are
shamans and so
goe is a place of religious worship now
what's interesting about goe is that the
religious site is the oldest but we also
find houses that are built later on okay
so what we think might have happened
here is that hunter gatherers
will come to a place now and then to
practice religion
because ultimately as human beings and
we discussed this last class we have a
yearning or we have a need to understand
why and religion solves this problem for
us also as hunter gatherer you need to
associate with other hunter gatherers in
order to find mates okay to find
husbands and wives to reproduce and so
this sort of religious center it's a
great time to come and practice your
religion but it's also a great time to
feast and to meet someone you can marry
and have children with okay so um that
was the original function of the
temple now these places are often led by
shamans and what makes them special is
that they are charismatic leaders
okay charismatic
leaders charismatic leaders are people
like madone Barack Obama Bill Clinton
okay they're people who for whatever
reason people just love them and want to
follow
them okay and so maybe what happened was
that these Char charismatic leaders they
built this place and they became like
celebrities and people came from all
over to meet them to hear them to hear
the religion and to meet other people
and over time some people even chose to
stay with them and build houses to
celebrate them okay and then when they
died what happened was they still
worshiped them in their death and so
this place became a temple okay does
that make sense so that's why theory
about go there are other theories okay
there are some people who will tell you
that space aliens came down and built
this place because it's so
sophisticated okay but so there are
different theories but the one that
Scholars most agree with
today okay is that it was a religious
Center any questions before I move on to
before I move on
this leaders religions or
Hors okay so that's a great question
okay where is where does religion come
from and this is something that we will
look at very closely next class and the
answer is is this okay even though we
all have the need for
religion we don't all have the ability
to produce religion okay so who these
charismatic leaders are are people who
who have visions or dreams of God or the
spirit world okay and then they present
their Visions to other people and we
have people like this throughout human
history right so think of Jesus think of
Muhammad F of
Buddha F of
confusious right these are people who
have these
visions of God or of spiritual ality or
of a new world and present to people and
because they're charismatic they're able
to attract followers and spread their
religion and that's that's what probably
happened here as well because as as you
can see from this picture it was very
hard work to build this Temple okay this
is 11,000 years ago they didn't have
bulldozers they didn't have shovels okay
this all by hand so for them to want to
D dedicate their lives to building this
Temple because it took a long long time
right it took years and years and
hundreds of people well you needed
something called religious devotion
right Faith does that make sense okay
and again throughout human history we've
seen this right so think of Christians
think of Buddhists think of uh Muslims
religious religious Faith so that's what
built this okay so so does that answer
your question okay any more questions
before before I I I
continue
yeah okay um so that's a good question
why is a temple structured like this
okay and the answer is that there's
cosmological significance to the
structure meaning that on a certain time
of the year what will happen is that the
sun will hit this place in a certain way
so it's almost like a clock does that
make sense to you guys they designed
this in a way so they can tell time but
their intention was not to tell time
their intention was to connect with the
outer world right does that make sense
you guys so they were extremely
sophisticated they knew a lot about the
way the Stars
worked okay so basically for them this
is science okay we we today we say this
is a religion but their science back
then is no different from our science
today okay does that answer your
question okay and you had a
question okay um so if you talk to any
religious people they saw it okay they
were there they talked to God right
right so so we're like well you know
that doesn't make any sense but they
really believe it and that's why they're
able to convince their
followers okay so you go so so in the
future we will look at someone like
Muhammad who had religious Visions in a
cave and like you're like did he really
see an angel well he thought he really
did
okay
and in fact if we in our research what
we discovered is that people used who
who use something called psychedelics
okay do you know what psychedelics
are psychedelics are drugs what drugs
and what these drugs do is they shift
your
neural um
system so that you see the world in a
different way when you do that you're
able to have different Visions okay but
we also know that if you go hungry for a
long time or if you meditate for a long
time you're able to see different things
so from their perspective they actually
saw this thing okay even though like we
don't think it actually happened does
that make sense for them it's true but
maybe for us it's not so true okay all
right any more questions before I I go
on all
right
so so these are great questions and um
keep on asking them okay and these are
hard questions that we will go over the
next few classes on so let me show you
another picture picture
okay this is what is in the pillars at
goe Okay now what's really interesting
about these pictures and okay is that
these are
animals in the motion of hunting so the
Fox right the way the fox hunts is the
fox jumps up in the air and then goes
down and attacks the prey so this is in
the motion of attack why would they do
that what's the point of having animals
on these pillars why would they do
that good okay yes okay so um what's
really important to understand is that
back then and again I'll explain to you
uh over the next couple weeks back then
we human beings did not see us see us as
separate from the other world okay does
that make sense animals trees humans all
equal so first of all if you're going to
kill these animals you need to ask for
their forgiveness otherwise their Spirit
their soul will haunt you okay they'll
take revenge on you so if you're if you
kill them you must ask for their
forgiveness okay and the one way to do
that is by paying tribute to them okay
that's number one number two is that we
can learn from these animals right
they're they're the best hunters in the
world so before we go on a hunting trip
we might have a ceremony to channel
their energy and power and
wisdom does that make sense okay and the
third thing is basically to appease them
or to become their friends right because
we don't want to hunt foxes we want to
hunt gazelle there's more meat than
gazelle they're easier to capture but we
want to be friends with the gazelle we
want to be friends with the lion okay we
don't want to be enemies so it's a sign
of respect to the animals so that that
was basically their religion and coming
together the religious Festival was
about celebrating the relationship with
these animals as well as channeling
channeling
their power their energy and the wisdom
so that they could go hunt as well does
that make sense okay so this is probably
one of the earlier religions that we
have is this clear to you guys so far
all right all right let's move on
okay so now this is Jericho okay and
Jericho is part of something called the
naian culture and the tafan culture
appeared about 13,000 years
ago or even more actually maybe 15,000
years ago in a place we call the Levant
okay the Levant is basically the Middle
East Israel and Syria what was special
about the naian culture are three
things first of all they were s uh
sary okay sedentary basically means that
um they they they basically stayed in
one place okay remember hun gatherers
they roed around they moveed from place
to place but they were hunter gatherers
who were senary okay they were not
Farmers they were hunter gatherers but
they stayed in one place and the reason
why we know there's a lot of evidence
but one reason why we know is that um
they basically hunted gazelle gazel are
like deers right and the thing about
gazel is their teeth color is different
according to the season so in the summer
and in the winter it's because they eat
different foods okay so the tea color is
different so we're able to dig up these
gazelle bones look at their teeth and
recognize that
oh um they were hunting gazelle in this
area both in the summer and the winter
which meant they did not move okay so
they were senary that's the first thing
second thing is that they had
domesticated
crops and the reason why we know is
we're able to dig up
seeds of crops okay vegetables and wheat
and barley which meant that they had the
capacity the technology to farm but they
chose not to farm does that make sense
okay so basically the way they develop
this technology is for gardening right
they were hunting Gathering most of the
time but some of them for fun for
pleasure have their own garden and
that's how they develop the
technology okay and the third thing that
was very important is that's I'm call
the The Cult of the
skull
okay so they probably worshiped
um uh animals but they also
worshiped ancestors and the reason why
we think so is we're able to find a
skull
in these places okay so they basically
took um someone's head skull and put
Clay on it to protect it and they put in
their houses to worship it okay so this
is the beginning of ancestor
worship okay does that make sense to you
guys so I want to show you this and it's
called the Tower of jerle when we first
discovered this we thought oh this must
be
a um evidence that
Jero went to war okay because had walls
and then a tower right the wars are are
to protect you from your enemies the
tower is to see your enemies coming but
then they did more research and realized
that oh no no no this Tower is a
religious Monument it's the same as goe
where it is cosmological meaning that at
the longest day of the
year the the mountain over here will
cast a shadow over the tower the tower
will cast a shadow over the entire
Village covering it all up in
darkness okay does that make sense you
guys why would they why would they want
to do that what what what does that do
for you have the entire Village cover up
in darkness
any
guesses why would they do
that excuse
me what do you mean by
that I I I know but if that was the case
you just move right so okay so so what's
really important is that this is like
right after after the last ice age okay
so it's actually pretty
cold okay they did this for religious
reasons right because when you cover
your village in darkness you feel as
though you are in
connection with the sky does that make
sense so they must have a religious
belief in which part of the worship is
to cover the village in
darkness the
vage um
that's a good question okay
so space is dark right you understand so
when you're dark you think that I'm
bringing space to our village so I'm I'm
collapsing the distance between space
and my Village right you make your
village you feel connect
to I I understand that but but your
village is is bright anyway and if
you're able to make your village dark
that's that's magic right that's that do
you understand okay so they design a
tower in a certain way so that it would
cover the village in darkness and they
could see that as magic and that's
evidence that your religion is correct
does that make
sense right because otherwise how do you
know religion is correct only by
performing magic can you show that this
charismatic leader okay who came with
this idea speaks to God
okay does that make
sense okay so let's look at certain
pictures of skulls okay because this was
actually very common back
then okay so basically this is a skull
they covered up with clay and They
Carried around with them all over the
place and this just two throughout the
world at that time okay an ancestor
worship
right so this is another picture
of the
uh skull okay let me ask you why they
would do that their an is dead why would
they do that why would they have to
skull
around where's the ancestors now
where's that
person the spirit world right some place
in other world and therefore having a
score around allows you to communicate
with that world and learn its
secrets you understand and some of the
secrets may be like how to construct the
tower in a way that you're able to cast
a shadow over the village okay so that's
their method of Silent discovery
does that make sense to communicate with
the spirit world through through your
ancestors does that make sense okay the
point I'm trying to tell you is
that their level of intelligence or
their understanding the world is just as
sophisticated as our understand in the
world
okay you understand we think that when
we go to science class we're learning
facts and knowledge but guess what maybe
a thousand years from now people will
look at at our science like the physics
and be like oh that was a religion too
okay does that make sense so in terms of
intelligence they were just as creative
and as sophisticated as we are today but
they just had a different set of beliefs
okay all right so the last place I I
want to look at is katah Hoak okay so K
Hoak
um is a huge place okay in as well um
pretty far from goe but about the same
place and this getes back about 7500
BCE and as you can see it's a huge
village and it and and we think that at
its height okay maybe this was around
for about 2,000 years but at its height
of development of civilization it had
about 8,000 people that's a lot of
people guys okay and the thing that
about K Hoak that stands out is first of
all it's huge okay second of
all um the they didn't have a place of
worship or government okay meaning that
all the houses were the same it was a
very egalitarian society everyone was
the same what's even more interesting is
that you go to every every house there's
a site the living room is basically a
temple onto itself it was it was a place
of worship and religion okay meaning
meaning that the first um like kind of
Hoak is a place where religion permeated
or was in every place they were okay so
we think that K Hoak is one of the first
religious
communities remember that
before um religious sites or places you
went to maybe once in your lifetime or
maybe once a year okay but it wasn't
part of your everyday life whereas in
kind of holak religion was in your life
from birth to death okay does that make
sense and the thing about kah holak
that's very interesting is at this point
their religion is extremely
sophisticated meaning that they can
explain everything using their religion
okay so their everyday life and their
religion was completely aligned together
so let me show you some evidence of
this okay so this is a painting that you
will see in every house or most houses
in kind of Hoya
okay all right so you're
like what is going on here
so again there are different theories
but let me explain to you what most
scholars believe to be the accurate
theory is okay so this is just a theory
we have no evidence for this but this is
what we
believe we believe that the people at
kind of Hoak they worshiped a mother
goddess okay because a mother goddess is
what gives life to everything right
think of Mother Nature think of a woman
giving birth to her child okay so they
worship a mother goddess and the mother
goddess is represented by the bird
because a bird flies all around the sky
right so the sky belongs to the
bird now now the bird can take different
forms um this is a vulture right so the
mother goddess can also take the form of
a
vulture so what's going on here why is
the
vulture with headless people okay
because there the way that they combine
ancestor
worship with their belief in the mother
goddess is they believe that when a
person dies what they'll do is they'll
put that person's dead body out in the
open it's a sky burial right you go to
toet they have Sky burials the VES will
come and eat all the Flesh and that is
the tribute or the sacrifice made to the
mother goddess okay so the mother
goddess basically cleans the body and
then you take the bones and you bury it
back in your house and you take the
skull and you keep the skull in your
living room to worship your ancestors
does that make sense so in other other
words it is an
extremely comprehensive or complete
religion understanding the
world okay is that clear to you guys
what the religion is any question so far
again but by the way guys a theory okay
but right now the most useful theory
that we have about this place any any
questions before I move
on
okay so what's going on here okay now
this again also is in kolak in many
houses so what's going on here okay so
different Scholars have different
interpretations of this okay
clearly this is a hunt right this is a
hunt and some people believe
that uh these human beings who are you
know part of the kolak people they are
mocking or taunting or laughing at the
animals as a way to subdue them to tame
them okay to domesticate them that's why
Theory but another theory is that what
they're really doing is
dancing because they are worshipping or
paying tribute to these animals they're
about to
kill or they're try so this go back to
go bye right where they're trying to
respect the animals right dance with you
we're friends I'm sorry have to kill you
but hey we're only taking your meat your
soul right is still going to be
born it's or it's going to go to the
spirit world okay so this is a way of
paying tribute or respecting the animals
they're about to kill or about to hunt
to maintain the harmony of Nature and
the relationship with nature does that
make sense
guys okay again what's really important
is that this is a pretty complete
religion right that explains everything
to these people and that's why why it's
so attractive to people right if you're
a human being you like you want to know
why well kind of H like the religion
there explains
why okay does that make sense so far any
more any
questions
okay so this is a picture of the mother
goddess okay again we have we have
debate about what this is some people
believe that it's just a fertility
goddess okay but others people believe
this is the mother
goddess and you think about it um if you
are a place like kah Hoak you're most
concerned about giving birth right
because giving birth is what rejuvenates
your Society so it makes sense that your
God the person you worship the most
would be a mother goddess okay
okay this is clearly a bow if and if you
see pictures of Kaho you you will see
that they have many many depictions or
pictures of B in their house okay and
what we believe again this is a theory
okay what what what we believe is
that if the mother goddess represents
life okay giving
life the bow represents vitality enery
energy and you and so it's the B that
gives the mar Gods the energy to give
birth right does that make sense so the
bow represents the male the monus
represents the female but only if the
male and the female conjoin they come
together are you will you have life okay
so this is another picture clearly okay
they're not hunting okay clearly they
are worshiping the bow does that make
sense they're paying tribute to the bow
okay so are we clear about this how
religion was a fundamental part of
people's existence when they chose to
become senary okay or they chose to
settle in one place so let's go back to
the original question and I'll take
questions the original question is why
did people transition into to
Agriculture and the theory that most
scholars believe is because of religion
it was because people had a religious
need that they came together to have
these religious festivals there are some
charismatic leaders who were so
brilliant that people chose to settle
down with them okay and so they became
senary they develop a religion around
the Cent lifestyle which included
ancestor
worship but over time time because
you're in one place you're going to
deplete the
resources of the people of the area
around you right of the forest which
means that you you must go to
farming okay does that make sense so but
then eventually because you have um so
much population and you farm too much
you're forced to move somewhere else and
when you move somewhere else you
actually bring your religion with you
okay and that's how we can explain the
transition from Hunter gather to
Agriculture and there was no one spark
or one moment when this happened we
think it took thousands of years over
time because ultimately the hunter
gather lifestyle is was so much more
attractive to people so much easier and
attractive to people than the farming
lifestyle okay but the benefit of the
farming lifestyle is that you had a
religion and and that's why people chose
ultimately to farm okay so that's
that's it and uh next class we'll
continue this discussion about early
religion and how people develop these
religious Visions okay to next class
we'll look at ice cave paintings that
goes back 40,000 years meaning that they
practiced this sort of religion or
something like this religion 40 to
50,000 years ago and we know through ice
ice cave paintings okay um so questions
before we finish class
is H is this clear to you
guys okay anything you're confused about
any questions before we
conclude
okay okay do you see it more
clearly and again this is all on the
Internet by the way so if you're you can
go online and just read up more on katah
Hoak okay these these places are very
famous we'll be discussing these places
throughout the semester
okaye Jericho and um
kak excuse
me we we discuss all three okay but I'm
introducing you to these three places in
future classes we'll go more in depth
into these places okay
becausee is a very interesting place
okay uh and we're slowly we're only
we're only slowly discovering all that's
there basically we basically uncover
about 5% of tee so over the next few DEC
we'll know we'll know more
okay um any more
questions any more
questions okay all right so next plan
class we will do ice cave paintings